uh men tend to do the right thing women
just tend to do the wrong thing they
they need to do an active campaign to
get masculine men in church because
right now it's feminine men and women
because these are the men that tell the
women exactly what they want to hear and
until the church does an active campaign
to get men back into the church you're
going to keep seeing stuff like this and
single childless women in the church it
they almost make God these women's
husbands and it's really sad because
what are these women going to do in
their old age
I mean there's a lot of things that
indicate Social Security is going to run
out a lot of these fallback programs for
women are going to run out so what's
going to happen to these women when they
get old
um and the issue is a lot of these
pastors and preachers get money from
single women they've a vested interest
in keeping women single I'm the nice one
guys I'm telling you I'm telling you
this